[Music]
on this monday night
back to school angst and assurances
we have really done whatever we can
to protect our kids the prediction that
problems
are coming i don't have a lot of
confidence in
many provincial governments india's
dubious new distinction
i don't think any living doctor has seen
such a long pandemic ever
plus the offside behavior by players
from england's
soccer team california's dangerous
infernos we grabbed everything that we
can what's fanning the flames and the
weather whiplash
on the way
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
it's a big week for canadian students
with the bulk going back to school
this year's list of school supplies
includes a mask and the final touches
are being put on classrooms
to make them as safe as possible in a
pandemic but there is growing anxiety
about how
it will all unfold nobody knows if
classrooms will actually be a return to
normal or
if they'll promote the spread of covid19
but as ross lord reports in our top
story tonight
we do know it'll be a huge adjustment
with the potential for even more
disruption
for many canadians back to school
shopping includes a search
for reassurance everybody is trying to
think make the best of it
but fear of the unknown is lurking uh
yeah concerned about another breakout
for sure
yeah and then concerned that the kids
will all be home
concerned about what's that going to do
for people working
yeah really worried about that i'm
interested to see
how everybody's going to work with
having to be socially distanced
while we're learning and paying
attention to other things
other than coronavirus leaders offer
reassurances classes can resume safely
with an emphasis on masks and distancing
where possible we have
really done whatever we can to protect
our kids but it's time to to get back
and move on
with covid but does moving on with covid
in the same
classrooms as before mean exposing
students
and school staff to the virus i have 22
kids in my room i have them about 60
centimeters apart
so that's significantly less than we
know
or we've been told is safe kerry vino
suggests teachers in nova scotia
are receiving mixed messages i have one
teacher who
thinks that their children don't ever
have to wear masks
and another teacher who thinks no they
do have to wear masks
in the hallways there's early evidence
from quebec
classes there have already resumed 47
schools have reported covet 19 cases
so far there's no indication the virus
is spreading within schools
but for the weeks and months ahead some
disease researchers
anticipate disruptions i actually expect
there to be some school closures
somewhere in the country before this
semester is out
because i don't have a lot of confidence
in many provincial governments
commitment to what needs to be done
not to mention the pressure on canadian
students teachers and families
to practice enough self-control to
prevent caseloads from climbing
ross lord global news windsor nova
scotia
caseloads are climbing in quebec for the
second straight day the province has
recorded more than
200 new infections east of montreal two
bars owned by the same person
are suspected to have violated public
health guidelines
police say they had to intervene over
the weekend at both places
at one of them police allege patrons
weren't following physical distancing
rules dancing too closely
and some not wearing masks the owner who
says he's doing everything he can to
ensure regulations are respected
could face a fine on the global scale
there are now more than 27 million cases
of covet 19
worldwide today india overtook brazil as
the country with the second highest
number of confirmed infections
more than 4 million people in that
country have become sick with the virus
signs of a second wave are emerging in
several european countries
in the uk the government is placing the
blame squarely on younger people who
aren't following the rules
and as redmond shannon reports a scandal
with england's national soccer team
suggests
politicians might have a point
india's metro trains are back on track
after a six-month
shutdown the government is trying to
restart the economy which
shrank by an enormous 24
in the last quarter but this reopening
is happening as the number of new cases
gets higher
every day in fact the curve has been
rising steadily
since april when it started we did not
think it would last so long
and because i don't think any any
living doctor has seen such a long
pandemic ever india home to 1.3 billion
people has passed brazil
as the country with the second highest
number of infections behind
the us some of our staffs are also
getting
affected with covet because of physical
exertion and not being able to take care
of themselves
notably india's death rate per capita is
much lower than the u.s
or brazil experts are unsure why
a young population inaccurate death data
and exposure to previous viruses could
be some of the reasons
a grim landmark in spain on monday too
more than half a million people there
have now tested positive
[Music]
this woman complains that spain has been
allowing in tourists
without any testing many of those
travelers come from the uk
which is seeing a similar second wave
but also
without a major spike in deaths the rise
in the number of cases we've seen over
the last
few days is largely amongst younger
people
inevitably it leads to older people
catching it from them
young people are getting the blame and
it doesn't help that two young players
on the england soccer team
were thrown out of camp for reportedly
breaking guidelines by meeting two women
obviously they've been naive
we've dealt with it appropriately
there's responsibility on every age
group to make sure that they
play their part in keeping each other
safe but in more encouraging news
russia says the final phase three trials
of its potentially promising
sputnik 5 vaccine will begin as early as
this week
redmond shannon global news london
there's a dire warning tonight from the
parliamentary budget officer
ishiru says the federal government's
deficit spending is unsustainable
unless it's reigned in but there are
signs the purse strings aren't being
tightened
the liberal government has been hinting
at an ambitious plan to be revealed in
their throne speech
at the end of the month michael couture
is in ottawa and joins us with the
details mike what's the timeline on that
well robin the message from the
parliamentary budget officer is clear he
says the liberals have to change
course within the next 12 to 24 months
or else either raise taxes or
reduce other areas of spending canada's
parliamentary budget officer yihu made
the comments in an interview on the west
block with mercedes stevenson
while he supports the economic stimulus
measures to counter cobit 19
he says something has to give without
the doubt that we cannot afford
deficits of over 300 billion dollars for
more than just a few years and when i
say a few years
i really mean a year or two beyond that
it would become
unsustainable the pbo's biggest concern
is the lack of a plan from the federal
government
to balance the budget trudeau and the
people around him
are living in a fantasy land
where they believe they can fund the
government
by borrowing hundreds and hundreds of
billions of dollars to fund a bunch of
vanity projects that don't help
canadians the ndp believes the best way
to get back to balance
is to go after the wealthy that means
eliminating offshore tax havens
putting in place of wealth tax making
sure that the the massive profits that
that the web giants earn is actually
subject to taxation
when the liberals presented their fiscal
snapshot in july there was no indication
of a plan for the years ahead
however the prime minister has hinted at
an ambitious plan
for a new direction after he hit the
reset button
by proroguing parliament as we move
forward in
reimagining what the canadian economy
can look like
in the coming years we have an
opportunity
to go greener we have an opportunity to
be fairer to reduce barriers for
women's participation for indigenous
participation in the workforce
the prime minister has also signaled he
wants to close the gaps for racialized
and marginalized canadians expect that
to be in the throne speech as well and
while opposition parties have complained
they've yet to be consulted on the
content of the speech as is the custom
a senior government source tells global
news all parties will be part of the
process before it's presented to
canadians
on september 23rd robin mike you reached
out to the office of the deputy prime
minister and finance minister
any comments on what the pbo had to say
well not directly but christian freeland
did say in a statement we are contending
with a historic worldwide
economic slowdown one for which canada
was well prepared
due to our strong fiscal position
relative to those of our g7 peers end
quote now
that all may be true but the pbo still
wants to see their plan
for the way forward robin mike look at
her in ottawa thanks mike
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
is out of a medically induced coma
doctors treating him in germany say his
condition
is improving after being poisoned by the
chemical nerve agent
novocek the outspoken critic of russian
president vladimir putin
became sick during a flight to moscow on
august 20th
russian doctors who initially treated
him denied there was poison in his
system
navalny was transferred to this hospital
in berlin he's able to understand people
talking to him and is being weaned off a
ventilator
a leading opposition leader in belarus
has reportedly been kidnapped
witnesses say masked men pulled maria
kolesnakova into a minivan
while she was walking in the capital her
abduction is the latest in a series of
disappearances
apparently engineered by belarus
security agencies
in the aftermath of the disputed
election which has sparked mass protests
yesterday more than a hundred thousand
people marched on the president's
residence
calling for his resignation nearly 700
were arrested
alexander lukashenko has led the country
for 26 years and is rejecting
calls for a new election he's been
pressuring opponents to flee
and then accuses them of working with
western nations to
undermine belarus the eastern european
nation is often described as europe's
last dictatorship wikileaks founder
julian assange was in a london court
today for an extradition hearing
long delayed by the pandemic assange who
has spent almost a year and a half in a
british prison
formally refused the u.s extradition
request
american prosecutors have indicted the
49 year old on
18 espionage and computer misuse charges
they pertained to a publication of
secret u.s military documents
a decade ago the charges carry a maximum
sentence of 175 years
in prison julian is a
publisher a publication is wikileaks and
a journalist
it's an oppression of journalism and
free
press everywhere in the western world
it can't go on it has to stop now
dozens of supporters gathered outside
the courthouse calling his prosecution a
threat to freedom of the press
assange spent seven years holed up in
ecuador's embassy in london
he fathered two children with his
partner while inside
he was dragged out over a year ago after
ecuador revoked his asylum
he remains jailed pending the outcome of
the u.s
extradition request the duke and duchess
of sussex have repaid the cost of
refurbishing
frogmore cottage near windsor castle a
spokesperson for prince harry and his
wife megan say they have paid the bill
in full the renovation estimated that
more than 2 million pounds was covered
by taxpayers sparking widespread
criticism
the duke and duchess promised to repay
it when they stepped back from royal
duties
the property will remain a uk residence
for harry
and his family californians in the
danger zone
coming up what some people were forced
to do to escape catastrophic wildfires
plus deadly typhoon the korean peninsula
gets pummeled
and later get out get out
no kidding when goading a goat takes too
much
effort
parts of california are under a state of
emergency tonight as
wildfires rage across the state more
than 14 thousand firefighters are
battling
23 major fires the flames have burned
more than 600 thousand hectares of land
more than 3 000 structures have been
destroyed and
eight people have been killed so far
firefighters have been unable to contain
the flames as temperatures soar to
record-breaking levels
as jackson proskow reports that's not
the only record for evacuation
there's never been a fire season this
bad in california
with more forest burned than in any year
on record and it's only september
we grabbed everything that we can this
is our first experience the long weekend
brought
frantic departures my biggest fear is
just hopefully my house hasn't burned
down
and harrowing rescues campers and hikers
were trapped at a lake sunday
after the only road out was suddenly cut
off by flames
more than 200 people had to be rescued
by helicopter
some took shelter in the lake until they
could be whisked to safety
at some point during the day when they
became trapped they were doing what they
could to
rescue themselves and make themselves
safe
some of which resulted in injuries
across california conditions are so
tinder dry that the rapidly growing el
dorado fire
is out of control after being
accidentally sparked by a smoking
pyrotechnic device at a gender reveal
party
extreme weather is fueling this fiery
nightmare
temperatures in the san fernando valley
reached an unbearable
49 degrees celsius on sunday it's
definitely hotter than i thought it was
going to be this weekend
so definitely just trying to stay cool
today 5 million households face the
threat of rolling blackouts as utilities
struggle to keep up with demand
extreme winds will only add fuel to the
fires
warnings extend up and down the pacific
coast and as far
inland as colorado where they're
preparing for weather whiplash
as a high pressure system moves in from
alberta turning extreme heat into an
early season
snow storm you just aren't necessarily
expecting
this much cold you kind of wish those
canadians to keep it to themselves but
they're not back in california
moisture in any form would be welcome
right about now
a break in the heat this week could help
firefighters gain the upper hand
jackson prosco global news washington
the u.s navy is desperately searching
for a sailor who has gone missing from
the aircraft carrier
uss nimitz in the northern arabian sea
the crew reported a man overboard sunday
after an exhausting search of the vessel
which is america's oldest carrier in
active service
the air force is also involved in the
search along with uss
princeton the missing sailor has not
been publicly identified
nimitz has been operating just outside
the persian gulf since late july because
of u.s tensions with iran
still ahead do police in hong kong make
a mistake in arresting a 12-year-old
[Music]
girl
mudslides and floods have wreaked havoc
in south korea as
typhoon hai shen slammed the korean
peninsula at least two people are dead
and two others are missing
along with heavy rain the storm packed
winds of over 120 kilometers per hour
leaving thousands without power the
storm comes just days after the
country's endured
similar chaos from typhoon mysak
hong kong police are being criticized
for the rough arrest of a 12-year-old
girl who got swept up in a protest
while out buying art supplies video
shows the officers trying to corral
a group of people the young girl
attempted to run away
an officer tackled her to the ground
while several others helped pin her down
the arrest happened yesterday during
protests against a government decision
to postpone legislative elections by
year
nearly 300 people were arrested almost
300 rohingya refugees have been found on
a beach in indonesia after spending six
months at sea
fishermen spotted the group making the
journey in a wooden boat
the police say they left bangladesh in
march and set sail for malaysia
but were turned away because of pandemic
concerns for years the rohingya have
been fleeing persecution in myanmar many
are living in refugee camps
in bangladesh canada is joining an
international genocide lawsuit against
myanmar
more than 850 000 rohingya muslims have
fled the country
thousands have been killed or have had
their villages burned down by myanmar
security forces
accused of ethnic cleansing
get out go come on it took a lot of
shoeing to get this goat out of a police
cruiser in georgia
body cam footage from the officer shows
the goat jumped in as soon as she got
out to serve papers
at one point the deputy sheriff was not
to the ground
get out get out
it did get physical but the goat
eventually did get out
it ended up eating some of her important
paperwork
the officer says she often leaves her
car doors open because she's had to
retreat from vicious dogs
when conducting police business and that
is global national for this monday i'm
robin gill
tonight your canada is cultist lake bc
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so send your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thank you for sharing your long weekend
with us donna friesen will be back here
tomorrow
have a great night
you